Des dissertations, j’en ai écrits pas mal
!
Pas vrai Haristote ?
J’en ai écrits tout d’abord pour préparer
et passer les concours ; puis pour le site
1000 idées de culture générale.
Je les commente même parfois en vidéo.
Vous pouvez en recevoir quelques unes en cliquant
sur le lien dans la description et en me laissant
votre adresse e-mail pour que je vous les
envoie.
Au total, j’écris entre 20 et 30 dissertations
par an.
Et à force, j’ai remarqué que certains
mots reviennent vraiment souvent.
Je suis Romain, lui c’est Haristote - enfin
bon j’aurais pu le présenter avant.
Voici donc Haristote (avec un H), je suis
Romain, et vous êtes sur 1000 idées de culture
générale.
Je vais donc vous donner la liste des 20 mots
qui sont, selon moi, les plus importants en
dissertation.
Est-ce que tu peux aboyer pour le top départ,
Haristote ?
Il y a encore du travail niveau dressage.
Le mot « problème » n’est pas forcément
beaucoup utilisé, mais il est quand même
important.
Il a surtout sa place dans l’introduction
- où on peut écrire par exemple : « Le
problème est/consiste dans… » - mais aussi
possiblement dans les transitions, pour prendre
un peu de recul et dire où en est la réflexion.
Si je dis qu’il est important, c’est parce
qu’il montre qu’on a bien conscience du
fait que l’exercice de la dissertation,
eh bien ça consiste fondamentalement à résoudre
un problème intellectuel.
D’ailleurs, le mot « problème » est la
racine de termes fondamentaux du vocabulaire
de la méthodologie de la dissertation, comme
« problématique », « problématiser », ou
encore « problématisation ».
Qui dit problème, dit questions.
L’adjectif interrogatif « quel », il sert,
comme le nom l’indique, à poser des questions.
C’est pour ça qu’il est surtout utile
à la fin de la problématisation - qui est
généralement la sous-partie finale de l’introduction
- ou pour formuler la problématique de la
dissertation.
Pour le sujet de philo « La philosophie,
c’est apprendre à mourir » - que je reprendrai
souvent en exemple dans cette vidéo - pour
ce sujet on pourrait par exemple se demander
très simplement dans l’introduction : « QUEL
est le lien entre la philosophie et la mort
? ».
Les questions de ce genre, elles servent à
mettre en évidence le problème du sujet
de la dissertation, et à le découper en
sous-problèmes.
Un peu comme le mot « problème », le nom
commun « énoncé » est assez peu utilisé,
alors qu’il a une vraie valeur ajoutée.
En effet, évoquer explicitement « l’énoncé
», ça montre qu’on est pragmatique, qu’on
est focalisé sur la résolution du problème
précis du sujet, jusque dans le détail des
mots.
Ce mot est donc un signal de pertinence.
Et ce signal peut être produit dans l’introduction,
la conclusion, les introductions et conclusions
partielles, et dans les transitions – bref,
à tous les endroits où il est question de
l’évolution générale de la réflexion.
Bon, là c’est assez évident : le verbe
« définir » et le nom commun « définition
» servent pour définir les termes du sujet
dans l’introduction, et éventuellement
dans le développement s’il faut définir
un nouveau terme.
Les profs le répètent beaucoup, qu’il
faut définir les termes du sujet ; et pourtant,
c’est parfois oublié, et souvent négligé.
C’est une étape cruciale parce que le processus
intellectuel à l’oeuvre dans la dissertation
est totalement dépendant du langage, qui
est le logiciel de l’intelligence humaine.
Disserter sans définir les termes du sujet,
c’est un peu comme vouloir utiliser un ordinateur
sans logiciel.
Vidéo d’un bug informatique
Je ne suis pas un expert en informatique,
mais ça me semble compliqué.
On a pas mal de préjugés sur les chihuahuas.
Par exemple, qu’ils auraient forcément
le poil ras - ce n’est pas toujours vrai.
En philo, en culture générale - et dans
une moindre mesure en histoire et en économie,
par exemple - la dissertation sert à vérifier,
voire à dépasser ce qui est communément
admis sur la question.
Du coup, le mot « préjugé » peut s’avérer
utile, surtout dans la problématisation.
Pour le sujet « La philosophie, c’est apprendre
à mourir », par exemple, j’écrirais bien
dans l’introduction : « Le préjugé moderne
semble considérer la philosophie comme une
science humaine, au même titre que l’histoire,
par exemple, ou la littérature.
».
Le préjugé, grosso modo, c’est qu’on
considère pas mal la philosophie comme une
matière scolaire de nos jours, alors qu’elle
était beaucoup plus que ça dans l’Antiquité.
On pourrait aussi parler de « lieu commun
», « opinion », « doxa », « sentiment
prévalent », « impression », « mentalités
», etc.
Ce mot aussi est relativement peu utilisé
dans les dissertations, mais il est important
sur le fond.
C’est vrai que j’utilise peut-être plus
souvent des alternatives comme « dimensions
», « versants », « portée », etc.
Ce que ces termes représentent, c’est la
nécessité de décrire les différents aspects
du problème à résoudre.
On peut par exemple dire explicitement que
« le problème a une dimension sociale, ou
économique ; une portée politique ».
Plus généralement, la description des aspects
du problème est souvent conçue comme la
première étape de la réflexion, comme le
prouve le bien commode plan aspects-causes-conséquences.
Je ferai une vidéo sur les plans de dissertation,
donc abonnez-vous à la chaîne pour être
prévenu de sa sortie !
Comme le disait Rousseau, pour résoudre un
problème, on n’a pas le choix, il faut
en identifier les causes.
Mais bon, le mot « causes » fait un peu
sec, pas très littéraire ; donc les correcteurs
lui préfèrent généralement le nom commun
« facteur ».
On peut aussi parler de « fondements », d’«
origines », de « sources », éventuellement
de « principes ».
Ces mots se retrouvent surtout dans la problématisation
ou dans la formulation du plan.
Dans un sujet sur la mondialisation, par exemple,
il faudrait s’interroger sur les facteurs
du phénomène : facteurs techniques ou technologiques,
juridiques, économiques, etc.
Comme pour le mot précédent, « effet » a
surtout sa place dans la problématisation
et dans la formulation du plan.
Si on utilise un plan aspects-causes-conséquences
- qui est plutôt bateau - sur le sujet sur
la mondialisation, alors on fera une troisième
partie qui traite des « effets » ou des
« conséquences » de la mondialisation.
Les alternatives de ce mot sont « conséquences
», « incidences », « produits », « fruits
», « aboutissements », etc.
Ces mots témoignent du fait que le processus
intellectuel qui est derrière la dissertation
est fondamentalement logique, c’est-à-dire
rationnel.
Et puis ils montrent aussi que c’est un
processus progressif, qui avance étape par
étape vers sa conclusion.
Dans le plan aspects-causes-conséquences,
les « effets » sont la conclusion de ce
processus intellectuel.
Ce mot qui est très utile en dissertation
sert lui aussi en priorité dans la problématisation
et dans la formulation du plan.
Pour le sujet « Philosopher, c’est apprendre
à mourir.
», qui constitue une affirmation assez forte,
dépourvue de nuances, on a par exemple intérêt
à se demander quelles en sont les limites.
Pour un sujet sur la mondialisation, on pourrait
se demander quelles sont les limites du phénomène,
parce que c’est en réalité une question
de degrés : il y a toujours eu une forme
de mondialisation, et inversement, encore
aujourd’hui, tout n’est pas mondialisé,
loin de là.
Cet exemple suggère quelques alternatives,
qui n’ont toutefois pas le même sens, comme
« obstacles », ou « écueils ».
Sur le fond, maintenant, parler de « limites
», c’est faire preuve de maturité intellectuelle.
En dissertation, il faut faire un peu comme
le préconisaient les sceptiques : penser
contre l’évidence apparente, contre soi-même
; pratiquer l’alternance des points de vue.
Le verbe « montrer » est surtout utile dans
le développement de la dissertation, parce
que c’est là que l’on présente les éléments
de réponse à la problématique.
Pour le sujet « Philosopher, c’est apprendre
à mourir.
», par exemple, on pourrait commencer un
paragraphe en écrivant : « L’étymologie
du mot « philosophie » semble montrer qu’elle
consiste, en dernière instance, en l’apprentissage
de la mort.
».
Si le verbe « montrer » est important, c’est
parce que la dissertation est fondamentalement
un exercice d’argumentation.
Bah oui, le but ultime, c’est bien de convaincre
le lecteur de la pertinence des éléments
de réponse qu’on avance.
« En effet » ou « effectivement » conviennent
tout particulièrement pour la deuxième phrase
des paragraphes du développement, qui servent
à expliquer l’argument.
Seulement, le problème n’est pas de trouver
où utiliser ces mots, mais d’éviter d’en
inonder la copie.
Comme ils sont bien pratiques pour structurer
le propos de chaque paragraphe, on a vraiment
tendance à en abuser.
La règle que je propose, c’est pas plus
d’une occurence par paragraphe.
Et puis, on peut aussi exprimer la cause en
recourant à « car », « parce que », « puisque
», « étant donné que », voire éventuellement
« de fait ».
Grâce à ces alternatives, les phrases ne
sont pas empilées arbitrairement, mais toujours
inscrites dans un cheminement de pensée le
plus clair possible.
L’adverbe « ainsi » a lui aussi tendance
à être trop utilisé en dissertation, donc
c’est bien de suivre la règle du « une
fois maximum par paragraphe ».
Les alternatives permettant d’éviter la
répétition sont « par conséquent », « donc
», « dès lors », ou encore « de ce fait
».
« Ainsi » sert généralement vers la fin
du paragraphe, dans la mesure où il appelle
une forme de conclusion.
Il est très utile car il permet de faire
des conclusions partielles - c’est-à-dire
de poser les résultats intermédiaires de
la réflexion - pour tenir le lecteur par
la main.
Ou par la patte, plutôt.
L’adverbe d'opposition « cependant » sert
surtout à l’intérieur des paragraphes,
comme point d’articulation du raisonnement
; ou bien dans la formulation du plan.
Par exemple, pour le sujet « Philosopher,
c’est apprendre à mourir.
», on pourrait formuler les deux premières
parties comme ça : « Si la philosophie apparaît
de prime abord comme une sagesse visant l’acceptation
de la condition humaine (I), son évolution
historique laisse cependant penser que la
conception posée par l’énoncé n’épuise
pas tous les possibles de la pratique philosophique
(II) ».
Les meilleures alternatives de « cependant
» sont « or », « en revanche », « néanmoins
», « toutefois », ou encore « pourtant
».
Elles sont souvent utilisées en dissertation
parce qu’elles en expriment la dimension
qu’on appelle « dialectique », ce qui
veut dire la structuration logique de la pensée.
En effet, l’opposition est le lien logique
le plus courant en dissertation.
Cet adverbe est lui plutôt peu utilisé,
mais il peut servir à la fin de la problématisation
; à la fin de chaque grande partie ; et peut-être
plus évidemment dans la conclusion.
Il montre que la réflexion doit aboutir à
un résultat final qui dépasse, en pertinence,
en profondeur, et en nuances, les résultats
intermédiaires de la réflexion.
Les alternatives éventuelles seraient par
exemple « en définitive », « au total
», ou encore « en fin de compte ».
Le nom commun « thèse » fait assez peur
parce qu’il engage à la présentation de
connaissances précises ; mais cela peut être
nécessaire pour donner - surtout dans les
paragraphes du développement - la preuve
d’une certaine maîtrise de l’histoire
des idées, notamment en philosophie, culture
générale, économie, voire peut-être histoire.
Pour notre sujet, on pourrait par exemple
écrire : « La thèse de Socrate est que
la philosophie est une pratique spirituelle
visant en dernière instance à préparer
l’individu à la mort.
».
Il est également possible de parler d’«
idée », de « théorie », de « doctrine
», de « conception », de « position », etc.
La préposition « selon » sert surtout à
introduire les références, en priorité
dans les paragraphes du développement de
la dissertation, ou éventuellement en accroche.
On peut par exemple écrire : « Selon Socrate,
la philosophie est une pratique spirituelle
servant fondamentalement à préparer l’individu
à la mort ».
On pourrait également écrire « Pour Socrate…
», « D’après Socrate… », ou encore
« Socrate affirme/avance que…
».
Proposer des références, ça on sait généralement
le faire ; mais on ne sait pas trop pourquoi.
Si on utilise des références en dissertation,
c’est pour étayer l’argumentation, c’est-à-dire
pour donner plus de force aux éléments de
réponse proposés afin de convaincre le lecteur.
Ce nom commun n‘est pas beaucoup utilisé
en dissertation alors qu’il est vraiment
pratique.
C’est déjà une bonne alternative aux mots
« thèse », « idée », « théorie », etc.
Mais surtout, il permet d’articuler efficacement
le raisonnement en prenant du recul.
On peut par exemple écrire « cette perspective
témoigne de… », ou « dans cette perspective
» pour lier deux phrases en faisant de la
seconde le développement de la première.
Enfin, le mot « perspective » peut aussi
servir à indiquer le prisme intellectuel
dans lequel se développe le propos - en clair
on peut zoomer sur le point de vue d'une discipline
en écrivant par exemple « dans une perspective
historique/sociologique/économique, etc.
».
Le mot « exemple » est plutôt peu utilisé
parce qu’on a peur, en l’utilisant, d’abaisser
la réflexion à des considérations vulgaires.
Or, un exemple, c’est un bon moyen de rendre
l’argumentation plus pédagogique, en clair
de mieux expliquer les choses.
Du coup, le mot « exemple » peut avoir sa
place dans la problématisation, ou à l’intérieur
des paragraphes, de préférence en soutien
des références (voire même en tant que
référence).
Comme pour le verbe « montrer », la présence
du mot « exemple » est la preuve que la
dissertation est un exercice d’argumentation,
où la force de chaque idée dépend en bonne
partie de la manière dont elle est développée.
Comme pour les termes « en effet » et « ainsi
», le risque est d’abuser du verbe « sembler
» dans une dissertation, parce qu’il est
quand même bien commode pour modérer le
propos.
Souvenez-vous de la phrase que j’ai donnée
en exemple pour le mot n°10 : « L’étymologie
du mot « philosophie » SEMBLE montrer qu’elle
consiste, en dernière instance, en l’apprentissage
de la mort.
».
Grâce au verbe « sembler », on peut prendre
des pincettes quand on avance une idée ; on
fait preuve de maturité intellectuelle en
proposant seulement des éléments de réponse
au problème, c’est-à-dire des hypothèses.
C’est important parce que l’humilité
est une composante fondamentale de la maturité
intellectuelle.
On n’est jamais sûr de détenir la vérité,
on peut toujours se tromper.
Alors, comme on a tendance à abuser du verbe
« sembler », on peut aussi modérer le propos
avec les verbes « paraître », « apparaître
», « pouvoir », ou encore, plus généralement,
le mode conditionnel.
La phrase que je viens de donner, « L’étymologie
du mot « philosophie » SEMBLE montrer qu’elle
consiste, en dernière instance, en l’apprentissage
de la mort.
», je pourrais la transformer simplement
en « L’étymologie du mot « philosophie
» MONTRERAIT qu’elle consiste, en dernière
instance, en l’apprentissage de la mort.
».
Celui-ci, c’est à vous de le trouver !
Dans chaque sujet de dissertation, il y a
un mot dont l’interprétation détermine
principalement le sens du sujet et oriente
la problématisation, ainsi que la résolution
du problème.
Dans le sujet « La philosophie, c’est apprendre
à mourir.
», le mot-clé est le verbe « apprendre
» parce que c’est grâce à ce mot que
l’énoncé définit la philosophie comme
un apprentissage.
Autre exemple : dans le sujet du Bac L de
philo de 2017 « Suffit-il d’observer pour
connaître ? », le mot-clé est le verbe
« suffire » dans la mesure où le problème
précis est de savoir si l’observation est
une condition suffisante de la connaissance.
Une fois le mot-clé identifié, il faut mettre
le paquet dessus !
Non seulement pour traiter le sujet, mais
aussi dans la rédaction : il faut donc le
saupoudrer dans toute la dissertation, jusqu’à
trois-quatre fois par paragraphe.
En faisant ça, on donne au lecteur la très
forte impression que la dissertation tout
entière est focalisée, comme un laser, sur
la résolution du problème précis du sujet.
Le mot-clé - lui ou ses synonymes, antonymes,
ou expressions comparables - est statistiquement
celui qui doit revenir le plus de fois dans
la dissertation.
C’est fini !
Tu en as marre ? Bah oui mais il y a beaucoup
de mots dans une dissertation !
Si contrairement à Haristote vous avez aimé
cette vidéo, mettez un pouce bleu et abonnez-vous
à la chaîne pour être prévenu de la sortie
de la vidéo suivante.
N’hésitez pas non plus à laisser un commentaire.
Et enfin, comme je vous l’ai dit au début,
vous pouvez télécharger des dissertations
entièrement rédigées par mes soins pour
les utiliser comme modèles en cliquant sur
le lien qui est dans la description.
Voici connaissez Haristote, je suis Romain,
et vous étiez sur 1000 idées de culture
générale.
N’oubliez pas que vous n’avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête pour vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée… et pour progresser
en dissertation.